the Ross Ice Shelf is the largest lump
of floating ice in the world so little
is known the surface of Pluto has much
better imagery than what's beneath
Raphael it's a lot of new stuff that
we're going to discover no one's ever
done this before it's exploration it's
going to be interesting from this point
on we've got four hours pouring into the
shear zone
very gingerly make your way through
what's essentially a minefield of
grasses knowing that it's it's my
responsibility to make sure that
everybody can get back to Scott based
safely it's huge huge deal but where
we're driving to us it's pretty much
directly south which is where the storm
system is going to come in from I guess
you're always hoping it's not going to
be as bad as it's forecasted it might
blow out and we'll have fun good
reasonably good weather but years worth
of planning gone into these events so
I'm getting moving and seeing how it
goes is kind of part of part of how it
has to work then an editor together I'm
looking at this wide expanse of nothing
and it's a bit creepy I'm seeing a lot
of white gonna get pretty used to seeing
a lot of way it's a hugely important
last shop so I'm just curious about what
drives it what keeps it where it is why
it's there in the first place really
gives you their perspectives that quite
a small fish in there in the grand
scheme of things and mother nature
really has control here I keep saying in
my head everything will be fine don't
worry about it but it's not you that
makes the decisions here at syntactic